all right
i'm gonna get started this is um lecture
um
14 of them 14 13. um the lecture today
is about um
attention okay
good um so why we end this class in this
class we talked a lot about preferences
so far think about like
uh purpose of describing in economics
what do people want
what makes them happy in one way or the
other we talked about time preferences
risk preferences and social preferences
time preferences how do people make
choices over time risk preferences are
how do people deal with risky situations
when some
things are uncertain and others are more
certain um or like sometimes
good things happen sometimes not and we
don't and there's a probability
distribution over those events and how
does that affect how you make choices
and social preferences is what we talked
about during the last few weeks which is
uh how do you
how does the presence of others affect
our choices how much do we care about
others
uh and do we decide or make choices
differently if others are involved
so now we should have done with
preferences it would have been something
saying like
we know uh we have no models to think of
ways to think about like what makes
people happy
uh the second part when you try to make
decisions is like when you look at your
environment
like what are prices like what are what
what do we know about others
what are our beliefs and what do we
attend to and how do we learn we get new
information so what information do we
have and like
what information do we attend to and how
to be learned when we get new
information
given to us and so um
we're gonna talk first about attention
in this lecture and then uh during the
next couple of times we're gonna talk
about
um uh beliefs and um uh learning
so what we're gonna do today is we're
gonna talk about three broad issues
one is i'm gonna provide you some
motivating evidence
about um attention he
had a little bit on this on lectures one
and two but i wanted to remind you of
that a little bit
then we're going to talk about two
specific papers one is a pretty famous
paper by brush chitty and co-authors on
any attention to
taxes and then we're going to talk about
a second
paper which is a learning by noticing in
particular we're going to ask the
question
of like how is it possible that people
do not attend to things that are
important in their lives
but you might sort of say well if
attention is limited that's all good but
then
we should sort of expect that people
attend to really important stuff so like
uh some sort of rational inattention
models would say well
it might well be that people are
inattentive in some ways
but really um uh it can't be a possibly
that the welfare losses from an
attention or large because if they were
large if there's
things that people missed and they would
pay attention to those things and sort
of shift their attention
optimally the learning by noticing
keeper is um
sort of one theory at least potentially
that
addresses this question the way this um
these movie perception uh tests uh
workers essentially
they look for what's called uh change
blindness so the way this works is like
often there's like one actor which is
like this guy here that i think you can
see probably right now um there's like
some guy who
uh does some activity if you're supposed
to watch the guy
and and then there's like a second scene
um
in some ways where the person does
something else
in this case uh the guy um sorry where
is he
uh the guy is taking a phone call and so
what happens then
is um uh sorry
this is essentially then this guy that
you see here then that takes a phone
call is a different person uh
all together and so that's called like
change blindness where essentially
people then tend to not notice at all
that now there's like two different
people
um in a scene there's other types of
experiments that do this as well or like
one version of that would be like people
go to like a bank
there's a bank teller and this is like
all sort of psychic experiments
there's a bank teller um
[Music]
here's the other guy so like you see
this guy he looks actually very
different to the other guy that you had
seen before
so people go to the bank there's a bank
teller the banks tell us oh yeah i'll
have to just
get something from the back and then
another person shows up who's like a
totally different person often looks
very different
sometimes wears different things and
people just don't notice
um at all and that's sort of the type of
experiment is called um
change blindness um
i've already shown you sort of the
gorilla test before i'm going to not
play it again because you know i've
already seen it but essentially it's the
same where like people are asked like
pay attention to how many passes people
um play in like a basketball game and
then there's a guy who's like in a
gorilla
suit who um uh shows up
and sort of like walks through the whole
screen and many people just miss
the suit now what's going on here um so
then there's
so there's a large number of these types
of
experiments they're called um uh change
blindness or inattention
um experiments and um there's another
version of that which is uh it's called
the dichotic listening experiments this
going back to broadband um
1958. they're essentially um
uh looks something like this where
there's like people who are headphones
with messages there's a uh uh on the
on one hand it's like an hour left uh
they're supposed to be like
ignored inputs and on the other end are
supposed to be attended inputs so the
person in the experiment is asked like
only listen to stuff that's i guess in
your
left ear these are like the attended
inputs i'm going to ask you some
questions about
that and then what you're supposed to
then do
is oh
so what can you sell are you still stuck
this is bad okay so let me um uh
one second i'm gonna unshare my screen
um exactly um give me a second so the
way this works is like you would see
um uh you would have a headphones on
and you have like um uh on one end you
hear like uh inputs that you supposed to
attend to
on the other here you hear inputs that
you're not supposed to attend to
and then um and then um
uh usually then you'll do you get
explicit um instructions to attend to
the message in one year
and then ask later about message in the
other year people can't remember it
and then uh what these experiments and
often are then when asked to keep a
number in the head people remember the
played message much less so essentially
uh what this sort of shows is that a i
guess like people
are pretty good at sort of shifting
attention in some way but attention is
limited in the ex to the extent that
like
when you're also supposed to attend to
something else at the same time
it's essentially like too much going on
and it's really hard for you to
to remember everything and so
um that sort of tells us to some degree
it tells us a i guess attention is
limited
we tend to focus when instructed at
least we tend to focus on stuff that's
important
right so like in the broadband
experiment if i tell you listen to the
stuff on the right here you actually
focus your attention to the stuff on the
right ear
you miss the stuff on the left here so
you can sort of direct your attention to
stuff that you think is important or
like you've been
instructed to focus on so that kind of
works um but at the same time
attention is limited in the sense of
like you can actually not remember
what's in the other
ear because you didn't attempt to so in
some sense it's not like you
automatically remember stuff you have to
pay attention to things
and then at the same time like when we
now exogenously reduce people's
attention
by um telling people to keep a number in
the head it was distracting
them in some way people uh are much
worse at like even playing like
the played message the message that
you're supposed to remember and surely
they don't remember the other message
either okay so then uh in addition
um which i already alluded to attention
is limited
um uh there might be different factors
that might affect people's attention so
what what factors might be important for
attention
it could be like your physical
environment in some ways it could be
like it's really hot
it could be it's really cold it could be
um other sort of like
threats in the room so like if somebody
you know if you're um
in uh in some place where like you know
you're worried that there will be wild
animals coming anytime soon
your physical environment could be um
really important could be really loud
there's some distractions could be like
you know social media it could be
uh other stuff that you're just trying
to do at the same time
maybe you're trying to like solve some
problems right now maybe you're trying
to
prepare for some for example i had a
phone call like just before our class
and i was also like trying to think
about like what to do in class and it's
just really distracting to have like
other things
thinking about at the same time uh could
be worries about others your own or
others well-being
um it could be asleep or what people
would say already
like people's physical environment
um we're going to talk about some of
this in the poverty lecture so they're
in particular
like um one thing that poverty tends to
come along with
is sort of a bunch of different uh ways
of in addition to obviously not having
money and many other
decorations uh poverty tends to come
along with like
lots of other um uh factors that might
use people's uh attention and that's to
do with like sleep it's to do with like
exposure to noise
uh it's coming with like worries about
people's health and so on and so forth
there's some question about like
practice like can you actually practice
attention and there's some people who
would argue at least in education maybe
at younger ages
suppose you like sit kids down and have
them like practice just focusing on
tasks like multiplications or whatever
any math problems
some of this some people would argue in
addition to just
um helping people um uh
learn math like actually sort of like
the the numbers and so on and how to
multiply
you might also actually just help uh
students
uh learn how to focus and how to pay
attention carefully to things
one particular like particularly sustain
attention and not get distracted by
by other things other distractions by
the way also are like temptations for
example so if i put like a
delicious chocolate cake in front of you
and have you and if you're really hungry
that might be actually really hard to
pay attention to whatever else you're
doing just because that's really
distracting um
to you okay and so um
we're gonna for now uh uh keep uh
sort of think about like attention being
fixed we're going to get back to the
issue of attention being valuable
and potentially being depleted by
issues such as poverty at the end and
the very last lecture but for now we're
going to look at like
think about like attention is is fixed
but limited and now we're going to look
at like what are the consequences
of that okay
so then one question you might ask is
like well you know this listening task
that i just showed you or like whether
like a monkey walks through like some
video
or the like it's kind of like a pretty
low stake situation who really cares
and so the one chicago view of economics
would be to say well
these are just low stakes situations but
you know um
once uh stakes are really high then
people will surely pay attention
so there's a number of different papers
let's look at this this issue but one
um um quite nice
example here is um from the stock market
um and sort of arguably an event of like
high economic importance because people
make a lot of money uh potentially from
it
so this is very nice paper by hubermann
and reaga from 2001
which has um uh uh it's essentially like
an event study and a case study
of like um a stock market development of
a company called andrea met
and this company in 1997
on october november has very positive
early results and a cure for cancer
now for any of these types of companies
like having like new cures and used to
do for medications the vaccines are like
are like hugely valuable because you
know they can sell a lot of
their product in the future which means
essentially
positive news about that means um you
know you'll have lots
at least with high probability of higher
probability um
uh large profits in the future and to
the extent the stock market
uh is an indication of that the stock
market uh you might expect the stock
market
to go up now then
november 28th the journal nature which
is very highly prominent
prominent scientific journal features
these news very prominently and the new
york times in fact reports on it on page
828 which is you know very much in the
back of the
paper and um in may on may
3rd this is like a whole like six months
later the new york times again
features essentially the same story as
on november 28th
on the front page okay now
um then on november 12
1998 the wall street journal front page
then
reports about a failed replication right
so essentially sort of to say well
there's a promising new uh early result
these early results are often like small
samples and it's not quite clear that
replicate really with like larger
samples and so on is this really like a
good cure
and so you kind of want to have
replications and really
only if you're able to replicate your
results uh is this actually something
that's useful and
that you can make money off now um
now what happened to the entrement stock
prices and so
the first question you might sort of say
is well in a world of full attention
with unlimited arbitrage
as in like if people took full advantage
of like the news and
reacted perfectly what would we expect
and second in reality what
what did actually happen so so let's
first ask the the first question about
uh with full attention what would we
expect
i guess there's a bit of a question what
happens in the first one there's a bit
of a question is there insider trading
or who gets the news in the first
place so one thing you might say is well
maybe the first one only the company
knows and sort of
uh uh maybe that's not public knowledge
and then if there's insider trading
maybe the stock market might go up
but surely like in number two if nature
prominently features that there's going
to be a bunch of traders a bunch of
people who like invest in this company
or not
if they pay attention they should really
know what's going on and they should
really
uh the stock market should go up
conditional on that on the november 28
news you know on may
3rd there's really no news here right
there's it sounded like we knew this
before if everybody was paying attention
before carefully
the stock market should have
incorporated the news is out sort of
like traders know
like um you should buy this or like
stocks like uh
this company is going to be more
profitable so stocks should go up so
really you should expect
um if there's full attention you expect
nothing to happen
in on may 3rd 98 and then if there's a
failed replication well
to the extent that like this means like
this um
uh this cancer cue is like entirely
useless uh the stock market should
essentially just go down to where it was
um um before now
um but what about in in in reality so
let me actually just show you
um so here's sort of the the reality of
this so here's um
there's not even like sort of there's a
the previous event's not in here but
like so here's this is essentially
the first story that comes out you see a
little bit of like an increase here
but actually quite a bit in relative
terms by something like you know five
percent
it seems like people just didn't really
quite notice what was going on
and there's also no trend upwards it's
not like the news is spreading across
people and so on
and then there's like a huge um jump now
in the new york times like right so this
is essentially here the
it's in the new york times but in the
back of the journal here up here it's
essentially the new york times
the front page and suddenly lots of
people pay attention
uh to news that's actually not news
because you know
uh that was already in the new york
times before to the extent that
everybody pays attention if there's
unlimited attention and unlimited
arbitrage we should essentially uh
expect
new effects um whatsoever so we see like
a huge spike in the stock market price
you know maybe the stock market
overacted a bit and went down a little
bit
but then um what we see here is then the
negative effect of like the field
replication
notice that here the stock market is
still quite a bit high the price is
still
quite a bit higher maybe twice as high
about like 20 compared to like 10 as it
was before
uh you know it's a little bit hard to
interpret that because it could just be
that
um you know maybe there's still a chance
that the cure
uh might work out maybe there's other
news about the company in the meantime
that are positive and so on
but the key part here is like the fact
that the stock market went up here on
may 4th
um 1998 really is sort of saying like
there's lots of this is lots of it's
news for lots of people and really it
shouldn't be news um there shouldn't be
any reaction because essentially
it's old news as you would say in the
sense of like people in 1997
uh uh in november 28 already reported
all of that is that um
does that make sense
okay so um and there's lots of examples
of these kind of things but essentially
um some of this is like in attention
some of it is also like confusion
i don't know if any of you have heard of
what happened to the zoom um uh
zoom stock market price uh stock price
so essentially um i don't know if any of
you have heard of this story so
essentially uh
zoom uh there's a company zoom which is
the the company that we're using right
now to record this video
uh the stock market price of zoom has
gone up a lot during the last like three
months
rightly so because zoom now has you know
assumes profits
has gone up a lot for example mit now
has like a corporate license of zoom
which essentially means like
uh thousands of people now are using or
can use zoom and that's an expensive
thing to do
it turns out there's um uh another
company that's also called zoom
um except for that it's a different
company and has nothing to do with the
actual zoom technology
it turns out that the zoom stock market
price for this other company
went up a lot as well the ticker for
that company
is actually uh as z-o-o-m so like zoom
um as opposed to like the
actual zoom company that we're using
right now their ticker is like
zm and so um at some point actually the
trading for that other company was
halted
presumably because people are very
confused and they were not really paying
close attention to
what is the right ticker what's the
right company that they're actually
buying they thought they were buying
zoom like the actual
online video conferencing company
well in fact they were just buying some
other company that's actually not even
doing anything
um anymore so there's lots of um stories
about
um people uh being inattentive even in
situations when
uh stakes are really really high now
then
you might say well how do we now measure
so now in some sense we have sort of
some
um some evidence here that people are
and sometimes somewhat
informal evidence that people are
inattentive now how would you measure
the impacts
of inattention um overall
if you wanted to sort of just measure
and demonstrate that people are
inattentive
in addition to what i've just shown you
what might you do how might you do that
if there's some information that they
usually get in the world
and they should have uh one example that
we're going to discuss is like
essentially prices or
taxes and now if you want to demonstrate
that people are actually missing
those prices or taxes what you can do is
now you can make it very salient you
make it really apparent to people
and then you can look at like when you
look at changes um
in uh and prices or the change of like
making things uh
from non-ceiling to sailing how do
people react now they maybe make for
example taxes very silly and
what happens to people's demand um for
certain products
and uh if then sort of making salience
changes people's behavior that then sort
of identifies
underlying inattention so if you just
people don't have access to certain
information in some sense that's less
interesting because that just means like
well i don't have the
i'm not that the information is really
available to me
but in some ways i could make
information that's really very salient i
could make it i essentially could sort
of reduce the salience as you say of
certain types of information
again information that should be
available to them uh for example like
suppose i do like uh
sales if i'm trying to sort of as a
company sell sell things you go to a
store and usually sales are made very
salient to people
now you could essentially just change
the prices without making these sales
very salient
and then you could look at like how
attentive are people to that
you know in a way that sort of in some
ways less natural right because
uh when people are in a way what we want
to demonstrate is that in real
people's real lives um there's
information available to them
and they're not really paying
sufficiently much attention
to it so if you can then sort of change
that in some ways and so demonstrate
that
now they are changing the behavior that
must mean that previously they had been
like
mis-optimizing if instead you did
something like um
if you sort of reduce people's um
uh the salience of certain types of
information that's in a way
somewhat less interesting because it
would sort of say well um uh
it doesn't really mean that they were
inattentive to start with it's more like
you're hiding something from people and
now they can't find it that's in some
way somewhat less interesting but i
think in principle you'd also exactly as
you say
um uh identify inattention
so um uh there's a few sort of type of
things that people
have done and there's um to be clear
there's often like a pretty fine line
between attention and memory
so one thing we could do is and this is
what maya was saying previously
you could make certain features like
taxes very salient that's what we're
gonna
look at next um in addition you can sort
of like um provide some information
when the correct response is known
already that's when i talk about
afterwards it's the study by
uh hanaidab so that's kind of like when
people have certain types of information
already
but then sort of providing that
information again or giving that
information in some sort of
concise form and sort of essentially uh
notifying people of the fact that this
information could be or should be
um important and when we now see people
react to it
then that doesn't mean that like that
must mean that before they were like
inattentive
another thing that people have done a
lot is like reminders reminders often
are sort of like um
uh you can think of these as like memory
issues and people just forget things
but in some sense memory issues and
attention issues are very closely linked
doesn't like if you forget something
then you don't pay attention to
something
so if i remind you of something now
you're paying attention to like for
example your savings or like your
medical appearance
like you should take certain drugs and
so on uh there's a number of studies
that essentially provide reminders to
people
uh and if these reminders have effects
you know then that must mean that people
were not at
paying attention to those kinds of
things often presumably because of
memory problems they just forget
sometimes okay so now um let me sort of
start with a very simple model um
to help us sort of understand the
results from uh
the chatty at our paper it's very simple
um
and very sort of just a sketch but i
think it's actually helpful to sort of
see what people are doing
so consider a good with a value of v
inclusive of the price
which has is the sum of two components
the components are
little b and o so there's a visible and
salient component v
and there's an opaque component o okay
and so um if you're now inattentive
the consumer or inattentive consumer
perceived the value instead of
perceiving the true value v
the consumer perceives the value b hat
which is um little d which is like a c
alien component so even if you're
inattentive the assumption is like
the salient part of the good you always
see for example what color is the word
or the light you always pay
let's see that and in addition
the opaque component the stuff that's
not salient
you're only going to pay attention to
with a fraction of one minus theta so
the degree of
in a tension so theta is our inner
tension parameter
and see that sort of measures how much
are you paying attention to stuff that's
not particularly salient so for theta
equals zero
you're back to the cases before for
theta equals zero v hat
equals v um which is essentially just a
standard case
if theta were like one so theta is
supposed to be between zero and one if
theta is one
then essentially you're not paying
attention at all to the opaque component
uh and anywhere in between essentially
then uh you're paying only partial
attention
to the opaque component so the
interpretation is like
each individual essentially
sees the beat so he sees o to some
degree but process it only partially to
the degree
of of theta of course whether you
actually see it or not processes or
whether you sort of miss it entirely
it's in some sense like a philosophical
question but think about like
everybody has at least in principle
access to the component oh
but um um they only
process it and pay attention to it only
um uh to some degree
uh okay so um teddy now applies this
model essentially to
uh taxes so one very interesting feature
um
about some taxes is the fact that like
sales tax is only added at the register
right so you
in some at least in most cases
you would like um shop um and then in
in the store and then the sales tax only
at the end once you actually go to the
store
um will be um uh added
now um people are not
people know when you ask people directly
what is the sales tax in your state
people actually on average pretty good
at knowing this so it's not like people
don't
know that there's a sales tax but um
they might just forget
um that there are sales taxes um uh uh
for goods
so now what you can do now is like um
you can compare
the demand response to uh sales tax
changes versus
um uh the demand response to other price
changes
right so like if you see prices
fluctuating um in a store
over time or across goods um
presumably everybody sees those price
changes uh overall if these are like
uh price changes that are not related to
sales taxes
the reason being like once you're in the
store you're going to look at prices
you're going to see is the price high or
low even before you go to the register
so presumably you see the price tag
pretty much most of the time in contrast
when you look at
sales tax changes if the sales taxes
goes up for some reason
or if there's a sales tax or some items
versus others
you might just miss that by at the time
when you're sort of choosing the good on
before you go to the register
and when you once you're then at the
register you might sort of not even
notice
um that you have paid the sales tax or
you might be surprised and just don't
change your behavior anymore um
but at least notice it
so now what what do chattyadal do they
have data on the demand for items in a
grocery store
and um they have essentially the demand
d of the hat remember the hat is the
function of the perceived value which i
showed you here before let me go back
for a second
so you see if you had here is like v
which is the ceiling component plus one
minus theta
times o is the opaque component so that
the demand for goods
uh depends on the perceived value of the
hatch that people have
and uh there's a visible part as the
value v
which is inclusive of the price right so
when you look at like when you're in
a store you look at the code you see the
good you see whether you like it you see
the brand
you see the color and so on and so forth
you also see the price
right so like the the valuation that you
give that's or the value b that you
draw from that is essentially coming
like how much they want to have this
thing
minus kind of like the the price that
you see um which goes into the visible
part of the evaluation
and then there's a less visible part
which is just stuff that's essentially
hidden
and there's a bunch of different parts
to that that you might not pay attention
to
um which would be like ingredients or
the like
or is it like organic or not and like
but in particular the sales tax right so
like when you think about evaluation
um you would have to like essentially
however much you like the
the good you have to sort of um subtract
the sales tax
because you have to sort of pay taxes on
that good and that's sort of less
visible to some people
um so you might sort of not pay
attention to it so in this case
um it'll be um v hat is like b
now the visible component plus one minus
theta times o that's just what i'm
repeating what i showed you before
and that equals v minus one minus theta
times uh tp which is the sales tax
and now until the extent that people pay
attention to theta
uh the sales tax might matter uh more or
less okay there might be other sort of
opaque components that are unobservable
both to the experimenter but also the
person we can abstract from that so for
now we can essentially say the last
visible part is only
the state tax okay
any questions on this
okay so now um and this is sort of like
so now essentially what this gives us
now now we can essentially try to see
um if we have sort of this um uh
uh how can we identify this parameter
theta
by making things very um salient and so
the idea is now
to um make the tax fully salient let me
show you how this looks like in practice
here's some math but i'll go back to
this in a second let me just show you um
uh what this looks like in the
experiment so the idea in the experiment
is to say
um you see on the lower part here you
see like a normal
um uh price so you see an original price
stack here this is what the price tag
usually would look like so this would be
an item
i guess this is like brushes uh
this item would cost like 5.79
usually and then what they did in the
experiment they essentially added a tag
where they said now here
579 plus sales tax is 622
and now we make it like entirely salient
that uh there's a sales tax and we make
the true price um very salient
okay and now the question is like if you
do that if we if we go from like
um uh theta being like
for example say 5.5 you only like
partially um
uh observe the sales tax if you go from
that to making the sales
tax fully salient what happens to
people's uh demand and
can you infer from that theta what
demand
what theta is actually look like so let
me sort of go back to this
so essentially what we're trying to look
at we're trying to look at
a change in demand when theta falls to
zero
why does theta fall to zero the
assumption here is that whatever theta
people have before so you might sort of
partially
or even uh not at all theta might be
like 0.5 or one
or whatever for people but now the
intervention that i just showed you
brings theta down to zero right because
now i make
it's fully salient to people what the
sales tax is
so the question is like now um can we
have an expression for the change in log
demand when
theta falls from when theta falls from
whatever is before
down to zero so now what we have is the
change in
um in log demand is
the um the
the demand that we had before this is
what i showed you before this was
essentially demand as a function of
b remember what i showed you here before
give me one second i'll go back
so what i showed you here demand is like
function of v hat and v hat is this
animal here it's
v minus one minus theta times t p um
now the question is like what happens to
demand when uh
or log demand here forget about the log
that's not that interesting that's just
for math
uh so here's the demand as a function of
what it was before
and here's demand when i now make um
things very salient
right so now here in this case here
theta equals zero and here
um a theta is whatever it had been for
now when you have this expression what
you can do is you can sort of
um uh linearize that sort of take the
derivative and sort of say um
what is this difference well there's
differences and you can sort of do the
math that's essentially um
a theta times a t p and then here this
is derivative
with respect to theta and um what this
gives you essentially is that the change
in log demand
is a function of a theta a function of
tau which is like the tax
and eta which is the um uh price
elasticity
so essentially that's to say is like if
we have now an intervention where we can
look at
how does demand or log demand change
when we do this intervention assuming
that this intervention brings theta from
whatever was it was before
down to zero we can look at like now
what happens to demand that's
delta log demand here that sort of lists
the definition and we can have that
that's an expression of
we can relate that to theta uh to t
which is like the tax as it is that's
something like seven percent
um and then eta which is the price
elasticity of demand
so that is to say if we have this change
in demand that we observe from changing
theta down to zero
and if we had the um the price
elasticity from like just other
variation in prices that we see in the
world
and if you have t which is just how much
the tax is
that would allow us to identify uh theta
and that's kind of like what the
experiment is trying to do so that
implies essentially so we can just
rearrange this we can just say
theta is i'm just sort of rearranging
things as minus
the change in log demand from this
intervention divided by
t times the price elasticity
okay and that is just to say essentially
what we're trying to see is like
intuitively that's just to say is like
once we make things very salient going
from like things not being sailing to
start with to making things very salient
how much does demand change uh uh there
and then we can look at like well
um for um so
in this case i guess uh this is like um
the taxes made very salient and then we
can look at
like well how does this compare to other
changes in prices
uh assuming that essentially people are
paying attention to prices anyway
so if you look at like um uh things
becoming more expensive by like one
percent
how much are people changing their um
behavior there
and now we have to sort of take into
account that like um what's being made
salient here is the tax t
and sort of from backing out the
relative changes in demand for like
usual price changes versus making things
silly and we can now try to measure
uh theta as like how much did they pay
attention uh before
so one way to say this is like for
example if we make
things very salient and the change in
log demand did not there's no change in
log demand
what does that imply for for for theta
what we learned from that suppose the
change here and demand is zero people
did not change the demand at all and
make things
very salient versus what it was before
so or predictably if
if theta equals zero here then um
these two expressions are the same which
essentially uh
means that this thing here is also going
to be zero so essentially
to the extent that our intervention um
changes large or induces large changes
in demand
that must mean that essentially um
[Music]
people were people were very attentive
to start with essentially if i'm making
the prices very saline and nothing
happens
well that means like um people were
already paying attention
um before now in the maximum case if i'm
sort of like
if people were paying no attention to uh
to prices as before um what would happen
then
well in that case i guess oops sorry
in that case um theta would be one so
essentially it would just be
going from uh we'd look at like what's
the demand or change in demand from
going like
uh v minus tp to v which essentially
just a change in
tp um so that would be essentially say
if the tax was like
um uh uh seven percent now we just have
to look at like what is the equivalent
effect of like a seven percent increase
in uh and the price um which is exactly
what we have
um here so essentially just to summarize
and i think the math is in some sense
not that interesting
but essentially to summarize it's like
the larger our reaction is to this
intervention
um the more inattentive most people have
been before
uh because of the inattentive to start
with um uh
uh they react more to making things more
salient so let me sort of show you um
what this looks like
in practice um again like the goal here
is to estimate the change in demand for
making taxes fully salient
again here's the original attack and
here's like the sort of the
experimental tag it's very very sealing
very very clear and very hard to miss
for people and the assumption
essentially is that people pay now
full attention to this new tag um they
have like a three-week period in which
this is like an experiment in california
they have a three-week period in which
they modify
um uh price tags of certain items so
they devote essentially at different
stores they pick one store and then
essentially they modify
the price tag only of a subset of
randomized goods
and they make the afters um uh tax price
um
uh salient in addition to the pre uh tax
price right the pre-tax price is already
very salient here
in addition they make the um after tax
price
um very salient and now they're going to
do what's called like a triple dip
estimate which is a sometimes a very
funky uh
or a fancy word or just and say what
we're going to do is we compare the
sales
um uh uh or like the demand during the
treatment periods to like the following
so there's a treatment period we can
compare how much of certain goods that
have
been treated how much uh do the sales
change
compared to like the previous week sales
for the same items
second we're gonna compare them to sales
for items
in which the tax was not made salient so
there's some
goods in the store for which the tax was
not made salient
and then finally there's going to be
like control stores right so we're going
to look at essentially
in the stores that receive the treatment
or in the store that receives the
treatment
what happens to the goods that receive
the treatment compared to the goods that
don't receive the treatment
we compare that to like demand before
the treatment was enacted for both of
those types of uh
goods essentially what's the relative
change in uh demand for
the treated versus the non-treated items
before versus after
so that's essentially what people would
call like a different diff like
difference and differences
and in addition to that we compare that
difference and differences
to the same difference in differences in
the control stores
let me show you exactly what this looks
like so this is a bit of a messy table
or like a table with a lot of
information but it's in fact
quite simple so what we have here is
like at the top
is a treatment store and at the bottom
there's like some control source so the
control stores
nothing has been changed so there's no
experiment there's no additional tags
and so on being added
in the treatment source there's going to
be control categories and treated
categories
notice that they didn't fully randomize
all the goods so it's not like if
there's one brush next to another
one brush has like taxes which is not
presumably because it's like they're
trying to minimize spillovers and
sunsets if you only
uh make this tax dealing for one good
that's next to another good people get
very confused because they're like well
why does this one have like taxes
um made salient and then the other one
not so now this is like across
categories where people maybe only pay
attention to certain goods in certain
categories to start with
so what we're seeing here is now here
these are like the control categories
and the treated categories
and we can look at what's called the
difference in differences we can look at
the change in demand in the treatment
source we're going to look at is like
essentially the change in demand in the
control categories and the treatment
categories
so what we see here is like we can
compare always
the uh how much is sold in the
experimental period which is like this
row here
compared to our baseline and what we see
is essentially
uh demand in the control categories was
going up a little bit by 0.84 that's
just because of seasonalities
maybe people like were just buying more
anyway for whatever reason
and in the treated categories uh over
the same period comparing essentially
the experimental period
to the baseline period a demand went
down
so now the difference in differences
estimate is essentially the change in
demand in the treatment stores
comparing the treated categories
compared to the control categories which
is just the difference between
this column and this column which is
minus uh 2.14
units okay so that's essentially how
much did
the demand change before versus after in
the treated categories compared to the
same change in the
control categories okay so that's
essentially like a
difference and differences um estimator
now they also have the control scores
why why would we want the control scores
as well why is that helpful to have
proposed like that included like
sunscreen and now it's getting like
warmer it's really like hot and
everybody wasn't
out advice like sunscreen then you see
essentially
people's demand or the control cutting
whereas the treatment kind of goes up by
a lot or goes down by a lot for whatever
reason
i suppose it's like you know umbrellas
and one week was really like rainy and
the other one was not rainy
and we see now essentially sort of
seasonal or other sort of differences
over time
uh in some of the categories that would
even if it's randomized it could just
happen to be in the case
so uh that would not have to do anything
with the sales tax being sailing and
that's just sort of by chance
so now it's very nice to have some
control stores where we can look at like
the same difference in different
estimates and something think of the
control scores in some sense like a
placebo
we can do the same things there's going
to be the control categories and the
treated categories
notice to be very clear in the control
stores the treated categories do not
receive any actual
treatment so we can do the same
difference and differences
and what we see here is now that um uh
there's essentially no difference here
so the
you know the managing the control
categories went up a little bit um for
whatever reason
in the treated and this is a little bit
smaller than in this other store this
difference is not statistically
significant but anyway the control
categories go up a little bit
the tweeted categories grow also up a
little bit when you do this difference
in differences estimate you will find
essentially no difference
like in the control categories there's
no change in the treated categories
uh compared to the baseline compared to
the control category so difference in
difference estimate
and the control categories essentially
is zero
and now what you can do is essentially
is the difference in differences
estimate
you can compare you cannot subtract this
number here
minus this number here which gives you
the triple diff uh estimate
um which essentially is the relative
change of treatment versus control
before and after and treatment versus
control
um stores it's a little bit sort of like
lots of differences
in your head but i think i hope this
comparison
from the table makes it clear any
questions on the
on the estimate of the procedure that
they're doing
okay so what we see here now is
essentially now making these
taxes salient in the treated categories
in the treatment stores
makes uh reduces demand right because
essentially demand goes down why does
good demand go down well like the
perceived price that people
face has now gone up um and now they buy
less of these goods presumably because
before they were not paying attention
now the price goes up and now
essentially um demand
falls as it should because now things
are more expensive
now and this is here the results the
average quantity sold decreases by 2.2
units this is units of the goods
relative to baseline level of 25 that's
an 8.8
uh decline and now we can sort of use
our formula and sort of
compute the degree of inattention
essentially now we can sort of
say okay now we know um you know what
the tax
so we know what the tax was the tax was
like a 7.375
percent we can estimate the price
elasticity uh
in some other ways essentially we can
say what happens if
prices go up by one percent uh for other
reasons what if the salem component
that's already sailing goes up this is
week by week um variation across stores
so if the price prices go up um what's
the price elasticity and the estimate of
those price elasticity is also given
from other
variation that's 1.59 and now we
essentially back out theta essentially
what we're trying to ask is like we have
a change in
2.2 units that is making
uh uh prices salient now the question is
like well how large of a change is it
relative to a change in prices of like
um one percent two percent
and so on um we know that essentially um
the price elasticity is like
1.59 so we can essentially just back out
uh theta and so what we get from this
formula
now is that theta is about like 0.75
which says that consumers react to price
changes due to sales tax
changes only a quarter as much as to
other price teams
so essentially consumers are are very
inattentive in fact the sales uh taxes
those sales tax changes
uh in fact they only sort of proceed
like a quarter as much um
as any other price changes um in the
world
okay and that's what it says you know
that's really saying like a lot of
people really seem to be missing these
things
that are not you and now if you make
them clean people change their
behavior they must have been inattentive
um to start with
um in addition to that kind of uh
evidence uh chattyadol also have some
evidence
on uh using non-experimental variation
and in some sense you could sort of say
the evidence that i just showed you from
that
from the store is a little bit weird
because in some sense you see these
different tags and maybe the tags like
uh raise attention to the price even
regardless of the tax and sort of you
know
it's a little bit weird in some ways so
it's quite nice to have some
complimentary evidence
of like a non-experimental um
panel data variation um
and so what they do is they look at
beer consumption and it turns out beer
um
tobacco and other types of goods have um
two types of taxes levied on them they
have like an excise tax which is
included in the price
this is highly salient during the
choice of process because essentially
it's in the price already so if like
taxes go up
essentially the price goes up and people
will notice if they pay attention or
since they pay attention to prices since
they're like
uh uh in the price tag already and then
there's a sales tax this is the tax that
we were just talking about before
that's essentially very opaque during
the choice process as we just sort of
showed
and now we can look at like variation
across states and over time
of like changes in excise taxes and
sales taxes and we can look at how much
do people react to excise taxes
relative to how much people react to
sales taxes
and that relative reaction will tell us
again something about um
theta and what um teddy i'll find in
here is a table um for that is
essentially when you look at
changes in excise taxes this is a tax
that's very salient
uh the price elasticity or like the the
yeah the lcd is above like 0.8 to 0.9
so essentially um when the the price
goes up by one percent uh people react
by about like
um almost like one percent in contrast
and there's some differences
in like um estimates but once you
control for things properly
people essentially do not react to the
sales tax at all maybe a little bit but
overall the number is like very very low
and now essentially the ratio of these
types of reaction
tells you how uh attempted people are so
essentially if you sort of divide
um say for example if you took like the
column number three if you divide
.003 by 0.86 and you have to do a little
bit of
additional math that's sort of
uninteresting you essentially will get
a result that essentially people do not
pay attention to sales taxes
they're one minus theta is eventually uh
close to zero but differently the degree
of inattention is almost
one theta is almost uh one so
essentially people do not
pay attention to these types of taxes
uh inattention is almost complete so the
substantial
consumer and attention to
non-transparent taxes
so what i showed you so far is um
essentially existence of inattention it
doesn't say
why people aren't attentive it could be
like people are
just can't do the math in their head it
could be like people don't want to
bother with it
they sort of say well it's kind of like
a small change so why do we really care
it could be that people are like buy
alcohol half of the time are drunk and
they don't pay any attention they should
have no
um um modeling in any way of like why
are people doing this
this is just saying like it shows the
existence of inattention in those kinds
of consumer
choices it doesn't say why people are
inattentive and you might sort of say
well seven percent of a tax is kind of a
small distortion
so like it might be actually optimal to
um to miss that which you know is a
reasonable approach
it is probably quite a bit of money and
quite a bit of distortion if you think
about it you actually
uh seven percent is not nothing but you
know if you like um have a lot of money
anyway you might as well just not pay
any attention to that stuff and if that
sort of
um helps you pay attention to other
things
notice that even then that sort of shows
that like the existence of inattention
it's just a bit of a question kind of
like how important is inattention and
this actually gets me to the next point
um which is a question of like why
should we care about an attention to
taxes why why is that important or
interesting potentially
the question exactly is like who's
paying attention who's not paying
attention and then who's sort of like
distorting the behavior potentially
there's lots of interesting issues about
like
heterogeneity and like who's paying
attention like but we'll get let me
talk about this in a second um let me
let me ask differently like
why is it that some taxes the excise
taxes are very salient and why is it
that other taxes are not salient like
what do you think about like uh
that is that an accident or why is it
that the taxes for alcohol and tobacco
etc are like very salient
and why is it that other taxes for like
shampoo or whatever
are actually not saline so one uh
there's sort of two
bro or this several objectives if you
took a public economics left you took
john gruber's class but also if you took
like 1401 or 1403
the reason why the government levies
taxes is one big reason is to generate
revenue right the government needs money
somehow we need to tax people
and issues of course is that if you if
you levy taxes on some goods
um versus others uh that can distort uh
consumer choices and there's essentially
sort of
um some theorems about like some
considerations about like
which goods should you um tax and
ideally you would tax goods that people
are consuming
anyway essentially what you want is like
people make sure so essentially when you
when you have taxes in some goods but
not in others
if people have different price
elasticities on some goods versus others
and if you increase the good
of one good um or all goods by like a
certain amount um if people have
different price elasticities
um then you might sort of distort their
behavior
right so if you increase um if you start
taxing one thing and not another
people might sort of shift to the other
good um and we don't want that because
presumably people are already uh
optimizing to to start with
now if people are inelastic to certain
goods if like people
need certain goods anyway and they buy
them anyway if they're inelastic
essentially there's a public goods
public economics would tell you or like
some theories
will tell you you should tax these goods
uh more
now distortion when people are so the
distortions are lower if people
um don't fully react to taxes it could
be for example if you started
taxing bread for example while people
everybody or certain
goods were like or potatoes where
everybody needs to buy these goods
anyway because
people need to eat well then um
they would be very very low people would
be very at least these goods would be
very inelastic
now and that's because they need those
things not because they're inattentive
but just because they need these types
of goods now there's obviously like
issues with like
um uh uh uh poverty or we don't wanna
attack the poor
too much uh but in general they kind of
want to tax things that are inelastic
and so
in a way if people are inattentive to
the taxes in a way that's great because
now they're not distorting the behavior
we can still get money
from them so in some sense actually some
of the
inattention for that purpose might be
actually good because now people are not
distorting their behavior
uh by um looking at those prices and
so being inattentive in some ways is
good but exactly as maya was saying was
like
for some goods and these are you know
often uh labeled as like sin goods
like where there's either externalities
or internalities for example if you
think about like tobacco or alcohol
their externalities tobacco for example
second-hand smoking is bad for others
for alcohol there's often externalities
in terms of like
uh drunk driving or violence or the like
so the government wants to sort of
increase the price of alcohol because
when people are
making choices of how much to alcohol to
buy they might not take into account
the effect of alcohol on others by
internalities i mean like people might
not
necessarily take into account the effect
of
alcohol or tobacco on themselves this is
what we discussed previously this could
be because of present bias
this could be because of um a biased
belief so the like
essentially people might sort of hurt
their future selves and the government
might sort of say well let's increase
taxes
uh because they're future selves people
might like that that might be a way of
helping people for instance deal with
self-control problems
so here peop the government explicitly
wants consumers to react
to their taxes the point is not to make
money from people and in fact sometimes
you're worried about making too much
money from people
the point here is really to change
behavior to reduce
the behavior that are being taxed so you
want to make such taxes particularly
salient
i mean i look at sort of the taxes on
alcohol versus the taxes on
uh some of the excise taxes versus the
sales taxes the excise taxes are
precisely salient
um because we want people to to to um
react to it
or the sales taxes are not of course
there's variation across places but it's
not an accident that we see this in the
world
the way that it is now one thing that's
quite interesting now
is um and i think jose was
william was saying that it's like when
consumers are heterogeneous then
there's a lot of quite interesting
issues for example if you have like the
poor pay more or less attention compared
to the rich or if only like a subset of
people pay attention
uh to those goods then in a way you
would sort of find that the average
elasticity is still quite low
but some people are actually distorting
the behavior quite a bit and others do
not and and you know
um that that gets relatively quickly
um quite complicated um and you know you
could sort of then get into situations
where you make some people a lot
worse off and some people better off for
making something salient
versus not any questions on all of this
okay so then um we get to the next
question and this is
getting a little bit of the question
that was asked previously about can an
attention or attention have
large effects and so you know
on the one hand you might sort of say uh
well you know people's choices for
example consumption patterns or
distortion distorted to limit attention
but you know you might sort of ask well
uh you know if
it's really true that like people's
consumption patterns have really
distorted that much if i'm like so much
worse off by like not paying attention
to things
well eventually i'm gonna notice this
somebody's gonna tell me
uh or like um uh you know
in a way like i noticed myself
eventually that like i'm doing things
really worse compared to my friends and
eventually if things are really
uh uh distorted like a lot i might
um i might sort of pay attention to it
so that the underlying idea is that like
uh potentially people are um rationally
inattentive in the sense of saying like
look
people's attention is limited in some
ways but um
uh it's only um it's optimal
for people to pay attention to things
that are really important and they're
the underlying question is like what
is sailing into people and how do people
decide what to focus on
and when people pay attention to
important things anyway um
if they uh if they have to and so then
the question is like well how is it
impossible that inattention could have
like large effects
uh anyway and so if the next paper is
like a good example of that
and here's like a very intuitive example
of why that might be so consider the
following situation you might
you you have been getting headaches you
go to the doctor
and the doctor asks you like whether it
gets worse after eating certain foods
and so what are you gonna say well the
answer will probably
be like um um uh i don't know
and why is that like why why might i
just
not even know the answer to that
question
an underlying theory in your in your
mind of like why you might be getting
headaches
and you know you might just not have a
theory that it's related to your food
consumption so you like
well you have lots of data in front of
you you eat every day you get
headaches and some days and not in
others you could truly pay attention to
it if you wanted to
but it's not even like a theory in your
mind so like you might even like
encode the relevant information if you
don't expect to have food allergies or
like gluten or allergy
like if you don't expect that to be a
likely cause then you're never going to
actually pay attention and you get like
infinite amounts of data on like every
day and headaches and food consumption
but you're never going to notice because
you don't have a theory in your mind
that that might be the case
now um and so there's a relationship
between attention memory you only
remember or pay attention to stuff that
actually are theories of yours and then
you only remember those things that you
actually paid attention to in the first
place
and so selective attention that may have
persistent effects on what we learn
essentially
you can have like unlimited amounts of
information in front of you
and you will never learn because you
never just had it on your radar that
this
information is actually relevant for the
issue at hand and josh schwartzen has a
very nice sort of model that
illustrates that another example is like
um
uh from medicine it's um many women died
from childbed fever
at hospitals in the mid-19th century the
popular theories were like bad smells at
the hospital
presence of male doctors uh the modesty
of mothers
that's of course um nonsense um
and the true explanation is germs
doctors didn't wash their hands
and again like in some sense that's not
a tricky thing to figure out if you have
the idea if you have the hypothesis
those with the idea that this could be
important and presumably some doctors
were washing their hands anyway
sometimes or not and they would have a
lot fewer depth
but nobody was noticing because he had
just nobody was paying
attention so once you have sort of the
right theory in mind
then you can test it and then of course
you can gather the right information and
pay attention to the right information
uh uh and or now um
sort of the basic model from uh and
trustworth's
beliefs today um matter for what is
being attended to
today which then affect people's beliefs
tomorrow and now
um if you if you if you don't attend
to the right things if your model of the
world is the wrong model
you might never learn to attend to
important aspects
of the world and so then forecasts and
beliefs may be biased and persistently
biased in a systematic fashion
and you might persistently misreact and
misattribute causes to
unimportant variables uh because you
have never even uh
considered the idea of the correct model
of the world
and so now the people i'm going to show
you is sort of an example of that
this is um seaweed farming in indonesia
which is not immediately obvious
why that's related but i'll show you in
a second so this is what seaweed farming
uh uh looks like
uh i'll do this relatively briefly but
essentially it's like add some uh
beaches you can like grow seaweeds in
like these roads
um and you see these round things here
um which are essentially pods
and so um the many factors are important
in seaweed farming
essentially sorry these pods which
essentially these round things that you
see here
they're essentially grown in different
lines and so
if you're seaweed farmers what's really
important is like line spacing
or potentially important is lime spacing
pot spacing and pot size how we got
these pods
now how does how does seaweed farming
actually work i've never done seaweed
farming myself but apparently this is
how it works
so farmers use what's called the bottom
method which is they drive wooden stakes
in shallow
uh bottom near shore and they attach
lines to these sticks
and then they take raw seaweed from the
last harvest and cut it into pots either
like these kind of brownish things
and the pods are planted by attaching
them at a given interval on the lines in
the sea
and at low tides uh farmers uh attend
the
uh the plots and sort of the seaweed is
then harvested after 30 to 40 um
days and so now many of the dimensions
couldn't matter the pot size the
distance between the lines the distance
between parts timing and so on
one nice thing about seaweed is there's
many different parts you can actually
try and learn and estimate
the importance of these factors over
time if only you paid
attention okay but the question is kind
of like
uh which which of these factors are
important and
um are people paying attention to those
factors
um so let me um and so what the
experiment now is doing is there's lots
of
uh farmers in the experiment they're
quite experienced they've been doing
this for a long time 18 years of uh
farming many of them are the vast
majority
so these are people who should really um
know what they're doing uh
in their cd farming experience and so um
the enumerators went to visit these
farmers and to measure them document
their farming methods
and when you ask them about their
current pod size and you just ask them
how big are your pods
people just don't know um the answer to
they also don't know the answer to
what's the optimal part size when you
just ask them how big are your parts
when you plant them they don't know
when you ask them what's the best way to
do it they don't know importantly they
know
uh exactly the answer to other questions
you know the length of the typical line
you know the distance between the lines
and they also have very clear ideas of
what's optimal um
to do so but they seem to essentially
neglect the part-sized dimension
entirely
when they're thinking about what to do
and so
in the experimental trial now um they
did essentially different treatments
and the treatments were essentially such
that farmers were
provided experimental variation in
the different pot sizes and essentially
induced
to experiment with part sizes um and
in some um cases farmers were just left
on their own they were just induced to
do this experiment and the question was
like now
both farmers learned from their own in
this experiment
and then in addition um they also have
like an information condition where they
then sort of summarize that information
to the farmers
uh in addition so um
so the question is now um once farmers
are induced to experiment
you surely would think that people
farmers would learn now that they given
all the information that they need and
like here's the different pot sizes
here's the different profits that you
get from the different um
types of pods now they might sort of
learn uh on their own
but you know if you don't attempt to pod
size in the first place if you think
it's kind of like irrelevant
anyway even if you have induced to do
the experiment
you're not gonna learn um uh at all
and so then they did essentially these
follow-up surveys i'm gonna just skip um
so now what they do is they also
do like an information provision where
they essentially tell farmers
um that the the weighting they were
doing with everybody but in addition
they also provided
information and did some simple
calculations on like
which is the best um uh uh combination
of part size and distance
notice that farmers are liberated
they're able to do this on their own but
the experiment was sort of like just
providing this information to farmers
explicitly with a recommendation about
like what's the pod weight and what is
the optimal
um distance and so now what the
experiment finds is
um large uh gains from the uh changing
the farming methodology
um and sort of the trial participation
itself only has an insignificant effect
that's to say in addition then summarize
data for people
has much larger effect essentially sort
of like uh focusing people's attention
to things that they should be already
know uh changes their farming behavior
a lot essentially
evidence that people were not paying
attention in the first place even if you
make them
uh participate in a trial where they
should have really or could have at
least learned
things on their own um there's large uh
impacts of the trial if the data from
the trial is presented to farmers
um there's no impact of the trial on
dimensions that farmers had already
noticed
previously presumably because they're
already paying attention um
uh and we're optimizing um so now what
do we learn from this and let me quickly
sort of summarize
uh and let you go so we have systematic
learning failures even though all
information was available so farmers
simply did not pay attention because
they didn't think that part size was
relevant in any way in their lives
now and that's sort of a potential
explanation why people might not pay
attention even to important information
because if your model of the world is
just wrong
why would you even think that this is
important and the problem here is then
like there's never an opportunity to
actually learn you never even collect
information that might reject your model
because you're convinced that your model
is right
uh in the first place and so then you
know lack of attention might generate
arbitrarily large welfare losses you can
really screw up big time for a long time
uh and never really change your behavior
because essentially you never learn you
never even pay attention to any
information that might have available
that says your model
is is wrong
you